oh yeah
well this is you Jenny
thank you
Mr cook you're on the stop are you ready
good I'm good
really gonna need you to stick to the
script on this one I'm the CEO of Apple
Willis I'm not going to do anything
stupid please stop comparing me to Steve
Jobs no but nobody's comparing you to
Steve Jobs okay I just want you to focus
on the products and
please stick to the script okay you're
on in three you're gonna forget they
ever heard the name Steve Jobs
with all the first thing that I'm gonna
do is
c-o-t-s throw out the scripts
now
I'm supposed to come out here and tell
you about some bull new iPhone pad pod
dick [__] you've seen it I'm a bear I'm
a bear I'm a bit boring
yes that's exactly it
now let's just sit at this table right
here let's say it's Bill Gates huh
[Applause]
that's what I'm talking about and let's
say that this is our competitors new
smartphone
how about that
all right
and let's say that this right here this
is one of our competitors new eBook
reader huh what about that what uh-oh
looks like Wayne
foreign
who wants to see some of that classified
Next Level huh
did Steve ever show you that classified
no we didn't you can't do that they
haven't been tested yet this device will
allow you to teleport anywhere on the
planet check this out I am the future
come on
let's see Steve Jobs do that
[Music]
okay you know what it wasn't my fault
all right I I I had the money like you
said in a trash bag in the back of my
car and I was gonna go straight to the
drop spot
all right
no no oh okay okay okay no no hey hey
hey hey man ain't on me for you to get
comfortable okay because because I'm
telling you man what happened wasn't my
fault all right I I I I I I I I I drove
to the agreed upon location man
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
because there's no need to have anything
crazy in a paper bag I'm telling you
there's an explanation for what went
down
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay let's calm down
now let's calm down man there ain't no
need
oh not a juice box there ain't no need
to eat a meal and then do some crazy
with a sandwich container in a juice box
oh man come on
come on man just chill out a little bit
just so you need to relax man you need
to take it easy in real life oh
oh God damn now come on man don't do it
don't do it don't don't manage come on
man
eating a sandwich
oh man how you gonna sandwich me dog how
are you gonna sandwich me oh okay look
it's being crazy now it's not stop It's
gotta stop right now okay you cleaning
yourself up before you do something come
on man what you doing what you want to
know well I'll tell you whatever you
want to know man just please stop this
cold ass man I'm studying you dog please
oh no no okay okay maybe it was my fault
a little bit maybe it's my fault a
little bit but don't just what you want
to do with that juice box man we're
gonna do it that's we gonna do with the
straw
what are you gonna do with this job
listen listen no no I did it I did I did
it okay I did it I did I left the car I
left for three minutes so please don't
do anything Mr strong why aren't you
stop the fight fine fine
okay I got your point all right man huh
oh man that's a [__]
[Music]
will we be having any more problems out
of him sir
no
the
that's what I'm talking about
we're coming to the end of the first
quarter with the Rhinos in the red zone
for the first time gotta say Bill I like
watching these rhinos Ransom takes the
snap drops back with good protection and
that's a completed pass to a very wide
open Hingle mccrackleberry the rookie
out of Penn State nice ground by
mccringleberry you think he's happy oh
boy he is loving it down there
we got something of a shooting gallery
oh yeah look at that boy that is
something and oh oh wait we've got a
flag though excessive celebration yeah
well I see and I'm not sure about that
call I don't know Bill that was three
pumps in the rule book says you cannot
have more than two oh my gosh but look
at the kid he's pleading his case
yeah clearly three pumps Coach Johnson
definitely not happy about this call
five minutes into the fourth quarter
third and ten the Rhinos again
threatening to score can the Cougars
hold them big play coming here Bill
Ransom takes the snap drops back he
floats one into the end zone and MC
pringleberry pulls it down he's got it
oh my gosh for his second touchdown of
the day for this rookie he has got to be
feeling great about himself I'll tell
you man he's oh let's see now there's
two pumps yeah he's really testing the
boundaries and he's clearly gotten the
ref's attention here a third pump will
draw a flag no matter what God he just
did it again what now what is that the
second time now you have to flag him on
them yeah he had to you know Bill it's
just frustrating seeing young players
without the ability to restrain
themselves it really is it's hard I mean
the ref's gonna get you every time yeah
yeah absolutely uh see now the ref
agrees that's three pumps right there
and the quarterback Ransom under Center
last five minutes of the game rhinos are
Marching here again hard to stop this
team from scoring bill they have so many
weapons
Ransom takes the snap and it's a shovel
past the mccringleberry oh he's at the
ten he's at the five and touchdown Rhino
oh my great block by hard Dunkin show
and that's going to be tough for the
Cougars to come back from boy what a
career day from hengelman crinkleberry
the rookie out of Penn State oh he's
just amazingly fired up here today Jeff
you gotta love the way this guy plays
and he Oh see now there's one pump oh
well I cannot believe this kid you gotta
put your team first in situations like
this and the kringleberries just not
doing now there's two Jeff now if he
pumps a third time he will draw his
third penalty for today
everybody here waiting with Betty breath
that's right if it's three pumps the
ref's not gonna take it away no he's not
duration and intensity doesn't make any
difference Jeff let's have a look at the
replay here to see if indeed he did do
the three pumps all right no question
there is the first one yeah right agreed
right and then coming up
is the second one okay yes very clear
it's the third we'll see it it's coming
up right here oh yeah you're right
there's absolutely three pumps there
oh uh apologies to all those watching
with young children uh clearly
unintentional
Bernard
that's it and he talks too much that's
why I like you you don't talk you just
listening
and the captain has turned on The Fast
and seat belt sign got a little
turbulence coming up should be no
problem just remain in your seat until
the sign is turned off thank you for
your cooperation
excuse me I'm gonna go to the bathroom
fine excuse me yeah yeah I need you to
take your seat the fast and seatbelt
sign is on yeah I'm just gonna go to the
bathroom for a second I'll be right back
okay I understand what you want to do
unfortunately I'm gonna need you to
observe the fast and seat belt cyan
that'd be much appreciated
right it's just I read on the internet
that it's not against the law for me to
go to the bathroom while the fast and
seat belt sign is on so
but is it against the law though
the light is on
against the law
you see that there's a picture of a seat
belt on that side no but is it against
the lawn
but is it against her father what is it
against the seatbelt sign is on but is
it against the evil sign but is it
against the lights on
Amazon
long difficult you're being very
difficult
not illegal not illegal not illegal okay
illegal illegal
[Music]
sir I have to piss and I have to in the
toilet can you lower your voice I have
to piss and I have to
lower your intensity you're louder than
me you're yelling you're in my face
you're the one who I think needs to tone
it down right now you are screaming at
me you're hurting
my ear
my ear that wasn't a word you're not
saying a word this is a word
that's not that's not a word that's a
tongue trick
okay sir sir if you would like I would
not like to
I would not like to sit down what I'd
like to do
is go take the bathroom
because
it's not against
the law
oh I'm gonna go to the bathroom
okay
mark
with a k
oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
thank you
and your captain has turned off the
fastened seat belt sign feel free to
move around the cabin
thank you for your cooperation
okay all right everybody just uh let's
settle down and settle in and like just
totally let's get our math on okay all
right guys so
um
somebody's got a little extra energy
hey buddy let's okay let's just let's
knock it off okay
yeah you got me he got me right guys
Jimmy dude all right let's take our
[Music]
[Laughter]
seats
very good Bravo Jimmy I'm just kidding
you guys can clap
[Applause]
that was awesome oh and I thank you I
thank you for the entertainment man
[Music]
cheers
I don't want to harsh survive man
I'm gonna be honest with you're really
pushing my buttons now Jimmy maybe
driving me crazy
[Music]
you want me to write your name on the
board
okay Jimmy do you want me to call Prince
from Martel
that would not be bitching would it
because you know what Jimmy you know
what why don't you come up and teach the
class man hmm
wouldn't that be awesome
[Laughter]
no and then you know what I'm gonna do
Jimmy I'll just sit here how about that
Jimmy and then we can all watch how
you're being disrupted
oh I see that's supposed to be me right
all right Timmy okay I see that I did it
supposed to be me it's time to be done
Jimmy don't you dude
oh yeah
well this is you Jenny
um
[Laughter]
give me five give me five huh how about
that huh that's you Jimmy I'm Jimmy
I'm Jimmy and I need attention yeah I'm
Jenny I'm Jenny hell look at him
I'm Jimmy I wanna
get it
Mr flyer
principal Martel nope what no no no no
no no it was Jimmy it was Jimmy
principal Martel
hey it was Jimmy it was Jimmy
[Applause]
Jimmy Jimmy
[Music]
[Applause]
but you know